this episode of fun science is brought
to you by brilliance fun science fun
science fun science it's the science of
fun yeah these are the lyrics to the
theme song of this very show but despite
the fact that I've been making fun
science videos for years and that I've
written an entire fun science book
available in all good bookstores I have
never ever tried to explore the actual
science of fun but today that changes in
this episode of it's fun so what is fun
well surprisingly science finds fun hard
to define although we know that fun
brings enjoyment not all enjoyment
brings fun for example though I quite
enjoy listening to classical music I
wouldn't really describe the experience
as fun although someone else's
experience might be different however
although fun is subjective we all
experience it in the same way when the
chemical dopamine is released in our
brains
now dopamine evolved as a reward for
behavior that benefited our survival so
if you do something good for your
species like reproducing your brain
releases dopamine as if to say great job
do more of that
but science also shows us that it is
possible to have too much of a good
thing but take gambling as an example it
might feel fun to win at first but when
we repeatedly flood our brain with
dopamine and high dosages it can
actually change the structure of our
brain and thus our behavior this is what
could form the makings of an addiction
which definitely is not fun
but provided that it's not excessive fun
can definitely be good for you it can
help with depression for example studies
show that doing something fun with
others even if you don't initially feel
like it can still improve your mood
dramatically and fun can help us to be
more creative in a study where 1500
people were asked to list potential uses
for a jam jar and a paperclip those who
ranked themselves as most playful were
also able to come up with more ideas
like this one so paperclip container
pretty fun right here's a fun fact if
you can convince your brain that you're
going on a run for fun rather than as
exercise a great time then you'll
actually be less likely to eat
afterwards my run was my reward and
while making time for fun is important
apparently we have more fun when leisure
activities are loosely scheduled say
within a set window of time or better
yet completely unplanned do I and
although it is still fun to have fun all
by yourself we tend to have more fun
when we do things with others especially
if there are friends and what's a common
side effect of having fun together laugh
scientists believe that laughter is
related to the panting sound that
animals like chimps and bonobos make
when they engage in rough-and-tumble
play it's as if the laughter is there to
signal we're just playing and having fun
we're not gonna kill each other and this
signaling is helpful because play can
help us to learn things like social
rules establishing rank bonding motor
skills and managing stress and maybe
that's the best thing about fun and
possibly the reason that fun science
exists in the first place because fun
makes it easier for us to learn
so hope you had fun and I hope you
learned something and if you're looking
to learn more science with the help of
fun why not try brilliant the people who
built really an understand the important
role that fun plays in learning they
give you fun and challenging problems to
solve getting you hooked on learning
actively and helping you to master
complex concepts brilliant have loads of
science courses to explore but why not
start with their science essentials
course and re familiarize yourself with
the basics to learn more go to brilliant
org slash fun science and sign up for
free although the first 200 people you
go to that link will also get 20% off an
annual premium subscription anyway
that's all for today thank you so much
for watching and I'll see you next time
bye bye